foreign
the academy has a crisis team in place
and her name
Naga
okay
okay the pop icon probably isn't who
Jimmy Kimmel was talking about in his
monologue at the 2023 Oscars but it
doesn't make Gaga any less heroic for
her good deed before Showtime
the Oscar winner was making her way down
the red carpet when a photographer
tripped falling to the ground that's
when Gaga snaps into action offering to
help the photog get to his feet
with the crisis averted she turns back
to theater that means so much talent in
this room mother monsters become the
resident Good Samaritan of award shows
at last year's Oscars she helped another
Legend Liza Minnelli have a moment to
shine you see that yeah the public they
love you a week later Gaga was at the
Grammys kiss me more Doja cat featuring
sza
she lost to sizza who was using crutches
at the time and Gaga made sure the
singer's Ensemble remained intact as she
made it to the stage
congratulations
Gaga faced another loss at this year's
Oscars losing the best original song
category to RR
[Music]
everything will be okay
but not before she sang a stripped down
rendition of her nominated song from Top
Gun Maverick
[Music]
little monsters nearly missed out on the
performance Gaga planned to skip the
award show due to her filming schedule
for her upcoming flick Joker Folia do
Gaga will play Harley Quinn alongside
Joaquin Phoenix who returns as the
Batman villain but don't you let go of
my hands
so how'd the last minute 180 come to be
simple a source telling ET Gaga
genuinely just changed her mind and we
can't blame her for wanting to be there
the last time she performed at the
ceremony was
she did win her first Oscar all it takes
is to believe in yourself and I just
hope that people all over the world
tonight know that if you believe in you
and you love yourself and you put your
mind to it you can do anything anything
including becoming a red carpet hero
foreign